welcome to the lecture on principle
component analysis
principle component analysis is a
type of unsupervised learning where we
use
a particular data
model and
in order to do that we need the
following idea
which is the idea of distance to a
subspace
so here we're going to have uh
a set of d dimensional vectors theta 1
through theta
r and
when we take all possible linear
combinations
of those vectors we get a subspace
so in other words i'm looking at
combinations of the form
uh
x is equal to a 1
theta 1 plus a a2
theta 2 all the way up to a d
c to d and i'm allowed to pick the a's
any way i like and if i look at all such
possible vectors x
i can construct that's a subspace
and it's a d dimensional and it's a r
dimensional subspace of r
to the d
and we might write that as
theta a where theta
is a matrix whose columns are
the individual vectors theta i
and a is a vector
a 1 a 2
all the way up to a r of the
coefficients
and so the matrix theta times the vector
a
is equal to the linear combination
of the columns of theta and the
coefficients in that linear combination
are the a i's
and so here we have
a d by r matrix and i guess i labeled
that incorrectly so let me fix that that
is theta
r not theta d
so we have a d by r matrix
theta and that is the matrix that
describes our subspace first it defines
the subspace
and we can pick any point in the
subspace
by picking the vector a
now if we want to say i've got another
vector
x and i'd like to
figure out how far is it from the
subspace
let's draw the picture for that
so here is my subspace
here is my vector
x and this distance here
is what i'd like to know
then well what is that well every point
in my subspace here s has the form
theta times a and so
out of all such points theta times a
i want to find the one that's closest to
x
and that's this optimization problem
right here
minimize over a x minus
theta a and the norm of x minus theta a
is the distance
between x and a particular point theta a
within the subspace
now this is uh if i square that
objective function so i look at this
distance squared well minimizing the
distance and minimizing the distance
squared
are the same problem and so
this becomes a least squares problem and
we know
what the solution is to least squares
problems it's
gives the optimal a as theta dagger
times
x and theta dagger
is theta transpose theta inverse
theta transpose that matrix
and this works if theta has
linearly independent columns in which
case theta transpose theta
is invertible and theta dagger is c just
transpose theta inverse theta transpose
so that tells us what a is and once we
know what a is
well then we know theta a
is this point right here
and which is the uh the best
the closest point in the subspace to my
given point x over here
um and we might call this thing
x hat um
that's the closest point in s to x
people would call it the projection of x
onto s x hat is theta times
a which is just theta times theta
transpose theta inverse
times theta times x so here we've simply
substituted in
for a um
and i don't know what that transpose is
doing there
um because that transpose this
should actually read x hat
is equal to theta theta transpose theta
inverse theta transpose x
somehow that transpose got misplaced
and so if i want to know what the
distance is between x
and the subspace well that's x minus
x hat the norm of x minus x hat
and x hat is this thing here and so
substituting x hat in
gives me this rather unpleasant
expression
but really if you look at that
unpleasant expression it's really just
let's call this matrix w
it's the norm of w times x and w
is this matrix identity minus
theta theta transpose theta inverse
theta transpose
yeah so here's the picture i just drew
this is the case when r
of course is one when we go to one
dimensional subspace
that's s um
and then the subspace is a line there's
a theta
is a matrix which has only one column
which we might as well think about as a
vector
but it certainly makes sense and the uh
this um
c to the terms plus theta inverse theta
transpose
gives us an a which is a scalar and then
if i multiply it by theta i get x hat
and that's uh this this thing here
in this case will be a 2 by 2 matrix
because theta is a two by one vector
so what's our data model now we've got
the idea of
distance the data model is that x
should be near to a linear combination
of the vectors theta 1 through c to r
in rd in other words it's near to a
subspace
the parameter that defines the subspace
is this matrix theta which is a d by r
matrix so
we believe that there is a subspace
and for such a subspace uh x
all of the data points x are close to it
um now the quantity
r the number the dimension of the
subspace
is also called the rank of the model
and the vectors theta one through c that
are are called the principal
components or the archetypes this is
called
principal component analysis this is
called a pca
model we have some people call a low
rank model
and our loss function or implausibility
is simply the distance between x and s
squared
now it will be convenient to assume
that theta has also normal columns
also normal columns means that theta
transpose theta is the identity
of course any subspace that
i want to describe i can describe it by
a set of vectors and i can
choose the the vectors that i'm using to
describe the subspace be also normal
and so there's no loss of generality in
making this
assumption if you have a theta that
doesn't have also normal columns you can
compute
the also normal uh
a set of orthonormal columns which
defines the same subspace
by the qr factorization of the matrix
theta
so you take the qr factorization of the
matrix theta
and you get rid of theta and you replace
it with q
and then the set of linear combinations
of the columns of q
is exactly the same subspace as the set
of linear combinations of the columns
of the original theta but the columns of
q are also normal
so when theta theta transposes the
identity
the loss function is the distance
between x and s squared
which has this nice matrix expression
it's
the norm of w x squared where the matrix
w
is identity
minus theta theta transpose theta
inverse theta transpose
and because theta transpose theta is the
identity that's just identity minus
theta theta transpose
now computing this norm
times x well we have that's equal to the
norm of
x minus theta theta transpose x
norm squared which is
x norm squared
plus the norm of theta theta transpose x
norm squared minus twice the cross term
and we can simplify that in particular
the the norm
of theta times any vector v squared
is v transpose theta transpose
theta v which is just equal to the norm
of v squared and so
uh
that tells us that this term
here is equal to the norm
of theta transpose x squared because
it's theta
times theta transpose x and
uh as we've just seen norm of theta v
is the norm of v and this
here is minus 2
the norm of theta transpose x squared
because it's x transpose theta theta
transpose
x and that was
nicely add up
to give us minus the norm of theta
transpose
x squared which is a very
convenient expression right here
for the loss function
so now the empirical risk that's the
average
on the loss function the average of the
loss function on the data set
simply one on n sum over is one to n and
the distance from x i to s
squared and the pca data model says we
should choose
also normal theta 1 through c to r
to minimize this empirical risk
so we get a bunch of x's a bunch of data
we
then uh
pick the theta that minimizes the
empirical risk
and then we can use that model for
example to do
imputation
so this is the case when r is one
it has a nice interpretation
geometrically
we have all these data points shown in
green
here we're trying to choose a
one-dimensional subspace which is just a
line
and the loss function is the distance
between the point and the line
these red distances here
and the sum of the squares some of the
squares of those distances
that's the um
that's the empirical risk scaled by n
so we're trying to find the subspace
that best
fits the data
and we're measuring the quality of fit
by
the normal distance between a point
and a subspace in this case a point on a
line
we can look at this
in matrix notation so let's express the
empirical risk in matrix notation
as before we construct the data matrix
for the x's this is just the same one
data matrix we used in regression it's
uh
n by d matrix each row
of which is a corresponding
data element x i so the ith row of the
matrix x
is x this is little x i transpose
so the empirical pca loss is
then expressible in terms of the matrix
by
noticing that the sum of the norms
of x i squared is
uh the frabenius norm of
the matrix x squared and then if i want
to compute
theta transpose times x i
well i can compute the matrix x times
theta
and that will give me a matrix
whose uh ice
uh rho is precisely
theta transpose x i or
transposed notice that here
there should be a factor of n
there
now in order to fit the pca model
we start off with our in
data points x1 through xn we're going to
minimize the empirical risk
we've got the additional constraint that
we want
to find the theta that minimizes the
empirical risk
but also should satisfy theta transpose
theta is equal to the identity in other
words the
columns of the matrix theta should be
also normal
because the empirical risk is the
norm of x
minus the norm of
x theta
minimizing this quantity over theta
is the same as simply maximizing
minus simply maximizing
the norm of x theta f squared
um and of course the minus change the
minimum it changes the minimum to a
maximum
now it turns out that this there's an
exact algorithm for doing this
so it's not a heuristic
these algorithms are called the singular
value decomposition
or the eigenvalue decomposition in this
class we're not going to go into the
details of how
those work but it's worth knowing that
they exist
the their complexity takes is of the
order of n
d squared where d is the dimension of x
and n is the number of data points
and there are in fact more efficient
methods when r is much
smaller than d
what do we do when we've got such a data
model one thing we can do is imputation
and the idea is straightforward
we fitted a subspace here it is
we've got a data
vector with some missing entries so
suppose for example we only know
x2 then we know
that the true x lies somewhere on that
line
and we pick this point right here
to fill in the remaining x1 entry
and that corresponds to exactly what it
corresponded to
in our previous session on imputation
we minimize the loss function
over the unknown components of x
with the components of x that are known
fixed
now in order to find the
intersection point right here
the way we do that is we have to
find the a remember a parameterizes
the subspace so we have to find the a
corresponding to that
intersection point that corresponds
to minimizing this objective function
so here we're looking for the
the point a that minimizes
the norm of the difference between x
minus theta a that's the
point in the subspace which is as close
as possible to x
however we don't use the entire norm
because some
components of x are known and as a
result we simply
use only those entries of x which
are known and that gives us the sum over
all i in the known set of x i
minus theta a sub i
squared and that finds
exactly this point right here
and if we look at the corresponding
x-hat
which is theta a and look at the
i-component of it
that will give us the missing entries
of x hat now when we are
fitting our model we start off with
data points x1 through xn
and we would like to choose the best
theta
so that we are minimizing the empirical
risk
now the way we do that is we
look at the distance between x and s
well we've parameterized
the subspaces s by theta
in order to compute that distance in
turn we have to compute the optimal
a the optimal a tells us which point in
the subspace is the closest
x and there's a different a for each of
the different
x's the computation that goes into that
is this computation right here
we find the a that minimizes x i
minus theta a and that we know
is a i is theta
transpose theta inverse
theta transpose x i and if we're
restricting ourselves to only looking at
theta with also normal columns
then that's just theta transpose x
i because theta transpose theta is the
identity we can write this in a
convenient way
we can have a matrix a
where the ice row is the corresponding
ice a transposed
and so now the matrix a will be an
n by r matrix
and that a is going to be equal to x
theta
let me erase that and write it correctly
and that just says a is equal to x theta
simply says equivalently that a
transpose is equal to theta transpose x
transpose and therefore
that the i rho of a
a i is equal to theta transpose x i it's
simply writing this
as a matrix equation
now once we've got
the a we can correspondingly work out
the x
tilde the corresponding closest point
there's our subspace is our point
there's the closest point
this is x i and this is x
tilde i and x tilde i well that's what a
i
tells us x tilde i
is just
theta times a i
now we can write that as a matrix
equation as well
in the same way we'll write x tilde
having its components
x tilde 1 transpose up to x tilde n
transpose the in rows of x tilde
and then the equation this equation here
corresponds exactly to the matrix
equation x tilde
is equal to a theta transpose
so empirical
risk is the average
of the distance between x i and x tilde
i
if we forget about this the factor of
one on n
then that becomes the frobenius norm of
x
minus x tilde squared
each row of x being the corresponding x
i
and each row of x tilde being the
corresponding x delta i
and so the frabenius norms gives us the
sum of the squares of the differences in
the norms of the vector pairs
we could write this like this since
x tilde is uh
is a theta transpose and
a is x theta and just substituting those
two in gives us
x tilde is x theta theta transpose
another thing we could do is we can
simply say x tilde is a theta transpose
and so let's look at this expression
directly
and that says that well we start off
with x
and our job is to find
both an a and a theta
of course once you know
theta well then a is given to you a is
theta transpose
x conversely um
once you know a well then x tilde is
given to you
but here we're simply saying let's try
and find simultaneously both a
and theta and the exp the idea
here is that this is a matrix
factorization
we want to find a matrix a which has to
have the dimensions
in by r and a matrix theta transpose
which has to have the dimensions
r by d i guess this should say a
d here so that x is approximately
a theta transpose and the dimensions
look like this
the dimensions are
there is a
and that has to be approximately equal
sorry that's x
it has to be approximately equal to a
theta transpose where this is n
and this is d this is therefore n and
r and this is therefore r and d
now in general if r is small
one will not be able to find exactly a
pair of matrices a
and theta transpose such that x is a
times theta transpose
and so this is an approximate matrix
factorization problem
and what pca is doing is finding
the closest matrix to x that is a
product
of an n by r and an r by d
matrix
now the mapping a is theta transpose
can be thought of as an embedding it's
taking an x
and giving a vector a the vector x has
dimension
d and the vector a has dimension r
so this is an embedding which is taking
x
in which it may have a large dimension
and giving us
a an a which would normally have a much
smaller dimension r
would normally be much smaller than d
and so it's a dimension
reduction we can think about a as a
compressed feature vector when x is the
original feature vector
um now when we've done feature
engineering
in the past we've done things like
constructing products
and applying non-linear maps to x
to construct features but here
the embedding is based on the data set
the embedding is being learned
and so this is a learned linear
embedding
from the d-dimensional space of x's to
the r-dimensional space of a's
now one of the nice things about this
embedding is that
it approximately preserves distances
so that points that are far apart in
our original d-dimensional space are
also far apart in our r-dimensional
space
and points that are close are also close
but because r
is less than d it cannot do that exactly
and so it does that as well as it can
let's have a look at this
so this property that the distances are
almost preserved is called the
approximate isometry property of pca
an isometry say a map from
r to the p to r to the q a map is called
an isometry if it preserves distances
which means that if i've got two uh
i've got two vectors x and x tilde i map
them both
both under f i get f of x and f of x
tilde
and the distance between f of x and f of
x tilde is approximately the same as the
distance between x and x total
the most well-known simple example of
this is
f of x is q times x where q is a matrix
which is orthonormal columns
q transpose q is the identity
then uh we can see
that the norm of q
of q x minus q x tilde
squared well that's equal to q
times the norm of x minus x tilde
squared which is equal
to x minus x tilde
transpose q transpose q
x minus x tilde and q transpose q is the
identity
so this is equal to the norm of x minus
x tilde
squared now what we're doing in pca
our loss function is the norm
of x squared minus the norm of theta
transpose x
squared and the
the theta transpose x well that's
precisely a
so this is the norm of x squared minus
the norm
of a squared once you know x well then
you know
a and so what we're doing is we're
trying to make
norm of x squared approximately equal to
the norm of a squared
in other words this means that the
embedding is going to be as an
approximate isometry the smaller we can
make the loss function
the closer to an isometry it'll be
in particular we'll see that uh
often we choose r to be two or three
simply so that we can visualize the data
effectively
we'll be able to by picking rs2 we can
plot
all of our data points in the plane each
xi gets mapped to an a
i and these ai are two-dimensional
vectors
and often by doing that the pca
embedding picks for us and shows for us
a map of our data
in two dimensions where points that are
close
are similar and points that are far
apart are dissimilar
we'll see an example of that
so example we're going to look at is
called latent semantic indexing
the idea here is that we have a corpus
a body of documents a select a
collection of documents
each of our records ui will be a
document
in that corpus of documents we can look
at all the words
and count up the number of different
words that are in there and we'll call
that number d
the number of unique words in all the
documents
now now we've got uh
d we can number all of the words
that show up anywhere in our corpus of
documents
from one through d and that means that
gives us a very natural way
of embedding documents
we can look at a document
and we can set x1
to be the number of times word one
occurs in that document
x2 to be the number of times word two
occurs in the document and so on
so we'll have a histogram of the word
occurrences for each document and that's
a very reasonable
embedding
from which maps a document
to a d-dimensional vector
in fact we don't tend to use that
particular embedding but we use a very
similar embedding
an embedding which has the same idea
where x
the jth component of x is
approximately equal to the number of
times the jth
unique word occurs in that document
and is larger the more often the word
occurs
but it's not quite that
and let's see why not
now we're going to use two in order to
construct this particular embedding
we're going to use two quantities the
first is called the term
frequency of word j
and so that what that is is that if you
give me a particular document
i count up the number of occurrences of
word j
in that document and i divide it by the
total number of words
in that document so that tells me what
fraction of words in the document
are word j that's called the term
frequency
of word j in document u
now i can also look at a different
quantity the document frequency of word
j
and that is if i look at the entire
corpus of documents and look at the
number of documents in which that word
occurs
and i divide by the total number of
documents i have
um now why is this a good idea
if we just kept a histogram of the
term frequencies that would certainly
make a vector which would have large
entries
to words that show up a lot in that
document and small entries
words that don't show up a lot trouble
is is that
some of the large entries would be kind
of meaningless there'd be words like
the if and but and
those words are word sharp a lot in all
documents
and so as a result we would like to
scale in some way
to de-emphasize words which are
popular words in all documents and
that's what we do with the document
frequency
and so this thing is called the tfidf
embedding the term frequency inverse
document frequency
embedding and it's not quite the ratio
of the term frequency to the document
frequency
but it's the term frequency multiplied
by the
log of 1 over the document frequency
and this kind of does the following
if a word j
occurs very often in a document
and it doesn't occur very often
in all documents then
the tfidf embedding will be large
and here where
have a way of discounting
the occurrence of very common words
such as the
so let's look at a specific example uh
here we're going to have two texts
the critique of pure reason by immanuel
kant
and the problems of philosophy by
bertrand russell
these are both very famous philosophical
works
both in a specific area of philosophy
and they're
famous in part because they take
opposite opposing
views and these we're going
the way we've analyzed these is we've
taken 50 excerpts from each of these
books
each excerpt has about 3 000 characters
for each excerpt we've taken we split
them into words
removed any punctuation or
capitalization and that gives us
a total over the whole corpus of 3566
unique words
we embed these using tfidf embedding
we standardize and we apply pca
so here is an example of a thousand
characters
of count and you can read this and
get the sense of what it sounds like and
a thousand characters of russell
now um just based on a thousand
characters of course you can't
glean too much from the meaning and the
question is can we learn
something that would enable us to
distinguish these two documents
and so here this is the embedding that
pca
comes up with we've picked rs2
we've got a data matrix x which is a
hundred
by two thousand two hundred and sixty
two
um and uh
this is uh
a hundred different excerpts 50 from
russell 50 from kant
now each data point each vector x
i gets mapped to an a i
that a i of course is just theta
transposed
times x i and because we picked r is two
each document corresponds to a vector in
the plane
and so we can plot all our documents and
here they are
colored the blue ones corresponding to
cant the red ones corresponding to
russell you can see they're quite well
separated
and that's one of the things pca does
for us is it shows us
the structure it's given us an embedding
where it has tried to spread out
the features as much as possible
now we have
uh a theta which is
uh a vector
which is a matrix which is um
d by 2 has two columns theta 1
and theta 2. and the way we should think
about that
is that these are our
basis vectors for our subspace s
each entry of theta 1 corresponds to a
particular word
same for each entry of theta 2.
and so here we can take all of our words
and plot for each word
theta one and theta two the
corresponding entries
of so theta one i and theta two i
the corresponding entries of theta 1 and
theta 2 for word
i now what does this mean
for example let's pick a word let's pick
this word
down here which is representation
now the word representation here has
a theta 2 which is negative and a theta
1 which is quite small close to zero
and it means that if we have a document
in which the word representation shows
up
a significant number of times then the
corresponding
embedded vector a will have
an a2 which is shifted negative
by those words and an a1 that isn't
really changed
similarly if i look at a word over here
this word is about
that's got a positive 2
and a negative theta 1. and
as a result if the word about occurs
significantly in a particular document
then the corresponding embedded a will
be moved
so here's the origin will be moved
in this direction
so now we can look back at our
texts and we can say that
because kant's documents
are down here and
russell's documents are up here
that suggests that
words these words over here
are words that can't tends to use
and these words over here are words that
russell tends to use
let's look at some of these
i happen to know that there's
transcendental over here
and conception over here if we look
at uh can't
there we can see in the middle
transcendental
conception right there
and so the reason
why these documents
split up like this and that we can
distinguish
russell from kant is they tend to use
different words with different
frequencies
and that shows up and is detected
by pca now of course it doesn't always
happen
that a two-dimensional embedding will
split
your documents so nicely like this
but nonetheless this gives us a great
choice
for an embedding which will enable
methods
such as classification
or regression which we learned earlier
in the class
to do a good job and
we're seeing that here
yeah we may want need to use an r is
higher dimension
in which case we won't be able to
visualize it but it will still
make our classification and our
regression methods work well
now i think that brings us to the end
of the class officially we have one more
lecture scheduled for next week but i
think there is no need
to try to fit one more topic in
in one lecture and so we're going to
stop here
i know it's been a very challenging
quarter
and i appreciate you all working hard
on this class during such difficult
times
despite the continuing challenges we are
facing in spring 2020 i hope you've had
a
productive quarter and i hope you've
this class has gone well for you and i
wish you all the best for the summer